and they say we only review the big
movies look at us with the smaller films
we're cinephiles man I laugh at your
puny blockbuster on the way to have a
heart attack later in the film oh yeah
as long as we do that like a few more
times during this review you know like
by the end when you're in the hospital
like it's all gonna be alright guys well
we're here today to talk about a movie
called Mandy before we do that I wanted
to mention this is not a sponsored video
by Stardust but we've been posting a
hell of a lot on that app we just love
using it it's free to follow us the real
rejects on Stardust as a matter of fact
here's John Stardust reaction of Mandy
so we just saw Mandy that's pretty
[ __ ] insane
okay Nicolas Cage is incredible I passed
cosmatos amazing director's nowhere near
as fast-paced as the trailer would have
you believe but it's every bit as [ __ ]
up and weird okay the music is amazing
the practical effects are amazing the
cast is great it's just crazy
sensory just crazy visual yeah so we
post a lot on there even do like little
random 30-second sketches every once in
awhile that our total blots to do
there's a link in the description box
would love it if you guys could go ahead
and follow us like I said it's free and
we just do it for ourselves so please
follow us there anyway onto this movie
if you guys have seen the trailer for
Mandy I highly recommend it perfectly it
resembles the film and every it's not
misleading we might have said it in our
reaction yeah it's probably a lot slower
than what's being led on in the film
that's the main thing as you watch the
trailer and it's not deceptive about
what the movie is actually about but it
may lead you to believe that this is
going to be a fast-paced experience with
some misleading in all in terms of its
visual style
I did not see what's Panos because of
cosmatos Panos cosmatos George P
cosmatos who did like tombstones
yeah you could totally see that oh yeah
I did not see beyond the black rainbow
which I know you're a fan of and this
movie it's a very artistic revenge
horror action thriller there's a lot of
inspirations we've heard a Q&A that was
hosted by Kevin Smith which was
hilarious Q&A super awesome Nick Cage
and Linus Roache and the director Panos
was there and it was a very insightful
Q&A actually hearing it made the vision
for the movie even kind of clear in my
head that's the thing is when he
described the method of filmmaking he
uses and also just what his approach to
the movie was I was like yeah yeah you
totally translated because at the end of
the day this movie is a revenge movie
just with a very specific type of
personal blending style yeah he calls it
a revenge movie the director himself
because I'm like do you call this just
that but it is in a way because like if
you look at just a simple action of the
story yeah it's a revenge movie and then
if you look a little deeper like at the
themes and stuff if you want to go there
there's a lot more going on than your
typical revenge movie and it's a lot
more sort of abstract perhaps than your
typical revenge movie yeah there's a lot
of specific types of dreamlike sequences
and scenes of visions and whatever and
there's even some stuff that cuts a
animation that's very brief in the film
yeah but it's definitely spread out
throughout the movie I don't always
understand what it is I can't go you
know what this is definitely about yeah
I get the sense that a lot of it is open
to interpretation so while it has this
plot line of and we haven't covered the
plot Nicolas Cage is a lumberjack kind
of gentleman who lives out in the woods
with his wife Mandy who is played by
Andrea Riseborough they're a couple who
is very much in love with each other and
it's not like Hollywood hamed up that's
setting it up for things to go Terry
they seem like a real husband and wife
that really loves each other and I think
they have great chemistry and it's
beautifully told and you got to kind of
set that up yeah you spend a little time
just be really honest about yeah this is
a movie
takes its time every step of the way
because you can kind of dissect what the
movies about from the trailer of this
husband and wife and then there's these
cult-like people you're not exactly sure
who they are
are they Satanist Nicolas Cage calls
them Jesus freaks in the movies crazy
evil yeah they're just these insane
cultists and Manson s yeah they take
place in the 80s and you know one night
the cult leader played by Linus Roache
he catches sight of Mandy basically and
then fixates on her there's driving past
and then he's like I gotta have her and
he instructs his disciples essentially
to bring her to me and then after that
night everything's changed and you see
it what's interesting to me about this
movie specifically if we're gonna talk
about plot beyond the style as normally
all that is covered in the first twenty
five minutes of a typical movie yeah
that's Act one what we describe for you
and cuz and I don't mind going into it
because the trailer covers it for what
you have to get into for the crazy Nic
Cage stuff yet that's like the first
half of this movie this movie is not
really about the plot but more about its
execution and its style and its themes
and what I thought was really
interesting was whoa we we haven't even
gone into what the trailer pitch us is
the plot yet yeah we're about an hour
that's the one thing I can imagine maybe
affecting the audience score on this is
like the movie I think a lot of people
might be expecting happens later into
the film then you would necessarily
think this reminded me more of a 70s
movie in the way the plot is structured
because you do spend a good half of the
movie building up the situations so that
when the revenge can go off it can go
off yeah you know and and when it does
happen when when Nic Cage is about to
you know turn and by the way the cage is
crazy actor who does a lot of like
really bad movies and then in the middle
he'll come out with something like Bad
Lieutenant or Joe in this movie where
he's just amazing he's amazing yeah yeah
and and in a way you kind of need
somebody with his specific blend of kind
of crazy kind of zany but also capable
of turning in a really solid lived-in
poignant performance yeah you don't
really spend much
I'm with him in the first half of this
movie it actually feels like I could
imagine and we were talking with a
couple people after the movie two of
that you do kind of start wondering like
what's gonna be coming back he's not
really in the first half yeah it's been
a lot of time with the cults a good
amount of time with Mandy or Mandy and
Nick Cage yeah it feels like Mandy's
movie for the first half and then it's
Reds movie for the second half yeah
so that's why it's it's interestingly
structured and I actually appreciate
that because it's such a deliberate pace
and that pace I think can really turn a
lot of people off yeah for myself I
enjoyed it there were times where I'll
omit in the theater even though there
were times I was really appreciating the
pacing times I was like get to what I
saw the trailer especially because when
you cut a trailer like that you get so
many interesting looking moments in such
close proximity the more you start going
I want to get to the violence I want to
get revenge stuff is cool there is some
like pretty gnarly violence in this
movie and there were definite violent
moments that guard a genuine applause
from the audience yeah great great
moments both cathartic applause and also
just things that looked really badass
there's some really great practical
effects that they utilize for different
gore gags yes stuff they're really
striking and also going back to older
techniques that are kind of cool to see
again this is a movie where you need to
have a good seat in the theater yes
because a big part of what will make
this movie effective for a viewer is
being able to be lost in its hypnotic
style got to be immersed so you can't be
in a just a typical crowd you got to
have a good seat and you I mean luckily
we saw at the Egyptian and we got to see
at the balcony which is a reasonably
good see except uxp was leaning for the
entire night hey Slade next to anyone
who does that or if that person sitting
in front of me like guy just keeps
leaning forward and all I see is the
movie in him at a certain point like hey
Eileen bored sometimes when I'm watching
movie but you have to be aware that
you're gonna be in there blocking yeah
you have to be aware you're leaving that
part for because of this movies
dreamlike execution and for its hypnotic
style it requires patience it requires
you being able to get Lawson it's as
important to prep yourself for that I
think when you watch this movie because
it was very apparent that when you see
that this film is such a fresh rotten
tomatos score when we were done it was
more than just us going it was gonna be
a really big audience you could even
kind of tell some of the people that
were in the crowd because there were
moments where Nic Cage being hurt it was
very raw performance I'm sure he's being
crazy and it Garner's a genuine laugh
where it's like worthy of it then there
are other times where I'm like you guys
are just waiting for Nick Cage to be
funny crazy yeah you could just tell
that there's kind of its kind of spread
out really do funny crazy stuff I like
to see them yeah yeah totally I see the
thing for me about this is I definitely
can see there being a divide in the
audience score for sure
I think the difference the between this
movie and something like it only comes
at night or something where you get
build this crazy movie that doesn't get
crazy for a long long time I feel like
Mandy has all the craziness you're
expecting it's every bit as strange and
weird I think it's mostly gonna be the
pace that will take ya cuz it's not in
any way I don't think it's fun strange
ever even when it's even when it's
getting like really violent and stuff
it's kind of cool at earn gardens and
applause or there it's dark and grungy
though it is the movie even teeters on
the point where when it's getting into
revenge territory where you're like oh
we're about to switch up the pacing
we're about to go like hardcore fast are
we know it kind of starts playing like
that but then eventually slows down
moments pick up energy but the film's
overall pace doesn't change no not much
but I mean if you can appreciate that I
mean there's some amazing music that
goes along the compliments of Johan
Johan see ya and that's his last score
it's beautiful music
rest in peace yeah I mean if you ever
saw black rainbow that had a very
distinct score
and this is on the more heavy metal side
than the synth side even though there is
a good amount of synth to it as well and
this is also a movie that has some
amazing cinematography like you can tell
it's film stock I'm pretty sure it's
film stock and there are some both
striking images amazing use of light and
framing zooms and even like I picked up
part way through the film there are ton
of these really really slow zooms or
they're also moving the camera forward
about yeah there's there's one sequence
actually where mandy is telling a story
of her childhood about her dad yeah and
i had to start looking at the corner of
the screen because i was like are we
zooming in yeah moving the camera either
forward or back yes in those long zooms
you start to feel the room either
stretching or or compact yeah and it's
like things like that are so fine and
there are such deliberate choices that
you have to like even if you don't love
the experience of watching this I think
you have to appreciate the craftsmanship
of the movie and just the feat of having
it all come together well I mean you're
dealing with this very evil crazy evil
Satan like Colt in a way yeah the movies
sort of throwing you into the mindset of
this drug trip yeah it's really sensory
it's very expressive oh good it wants to
make you feel a lot of difference yeah
this movie is very much about its
atmosphere in town yeah yeah I don't
know who this movies for I don't know
you know I'm not sure who's gonna like
it because it's not exactly scary but
it's got its horrifying elements it's
not exactly an action movie but it's got
its action you know if you like revenge
movies it ain't John wick or Kill Bill
it's like who is this for yeah yeah but
it's not made for that
yes I'm made for a demographic it's a
very you can still feels a very personal
film yeah for sure it's very expressive
like it is the epitome of like arthouse
exploitation in in a way yeah and I
appreciate that a guy like this is able
to work now and to make something that
kind of defies yeah particularly easy to
identify audience or genre or whatever
because black rainbow has a lot of those
qualities too where you're like this is
kind of sci-fi kinda
were kind of drama kind of just abstract
and strange and sensory and that seems
to be the style he works and but between
these two films like there are a lot of
distinctions as well and I think he
makes stuff that's definitely worth
checking out he reminds me of like a
more abstract more aggressively
out-there Nicolas Winding roughen not
like a touchstone because like yeah it's
like I can see this being played in some
kind of weird double feature after drive
or something like that that's a weird
double feature but I feel like there's a
kinship between filmmakers like that I
just think panis is baby a bit more off
the beaten path than a whiny reckon is
but overall for me I mean it's
definitely one of those films that has
to sink in but the more I've thought
about it the more I again appreciate
just what they achieved in movies like
this usually go down easier for me on
repeat viewings like the first time I
watched black rainbow is the similar
watching experience where I was like
okay not quite what I was expecting but
also a lot of things I was expecting and
it's making me feel a lot of things I
didn't expect and then you know you let
those things germinate and I've loved
when movies can bring you back into that
where it takes a little time to figure
out your thoughts if you don't just know
immediately you know that if the idea of
a revenge movie by the guy who made
black rainbow sounds like a good idea to
you you'll probably like this yeah
overall say there's too much in it for
me that I appreciate it that I can't say
I wouldn't recommend I definitely would
recommend it but I don't know who I
recommend it to all right guys did you
see Mandy what's your opinion on it
what's your favorite crazy Nick Cage
performance
put it in the comments below you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation
please click that notification Bell
check us out on patreon we got TV show
reactions weekly Q&A a whole bunch of
goodies offer there and please do follow
us on the stardust app that's free and
we post pretty much daily on there so
would love to have you follow us there